Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Soy cirujano.
Desde siempre los cirujanos pensamos
que para tener más trabajo
tenemos que buscar más motivos
para operar más pacientes.
En mis últimos 10 años, mi investigación,
en mi caso en el esófago,
se basó en buscar los motivos para
operar cada vez menos a los pacientes.
Eso se puede hacer de varias maneras.
Lo hacemos, por ejemplo,
buscando genes para detectar
enfermedades más temprano,
como el cáncer, y así
no tener que operarlas.
Podemos ayudar a los tejidos
a repararse por sí solos
utilizando su propia
capacidad de regenerarse.
Esto lo hacemos con los andamios
biológicos, que son como mapas
que le damos al tejido para que utilice
su propia capacidad de restaurarse
después de un daño.
Y finalmente con las nuevas tecnologías,
podemos, por ejemplo, con un endoscopio,
hacer procedimientos y preservar órganos
donde antes había que operar y sacarlos.
La robótica nos está dando
un montón de herramientas
para facilitar estas tareas.
Lo que antes parecía ciencia ficción,
hoy es casi cotidiano, es alucinante.
Desafiar mis propios paradigmas
de tener cada vez
más pacientes para operar,
me dio muchas satisfacciones.
A mí y a un montón de pacientes
que evitaron tener
que hacerse una cirugía.
Con todo esto que les conté me di cuenta
de que desarrollando métodos
cada vez menos invasivos
tengo cada vez más trabajo.
(Aplausos)